I can honestly say without any  exaggeration have never been in a club I  think that's a good thing but never that  is an unbelievable Fall From Grace when  you get to be our age like if you were  actually the guy that went into those  clubs like John Travolta yes clearing  the dance floor and banging the hottest  ass in the city yeah to then just be in  your 50s with the dad bod I mean that's  like astronauts when they come back to  earth and they just start crying at a  stoplight  dude you meet me it's just been kind of  like you know yeah I had orange hair it  fell out and then I got an old sweater  on it just you know I kind of rolled off  a curve yeah I'm like oh this is nice  being 54.